we'd love to hear about your first day
and actually week and the screenwriting
program what were things that were
taught or were they all introduction
into what you'd be learning um it was a
little bit of both we had the first
semester we had three classes we had an
introduction to screenplay analysis and
that was with professor Hetson and that
was the beginning of his sort of
explanation of screenplay structure we
didn't actually write in that class but
that first class was sort of like a top
level introduction to the terms that he
would be using kind of a general
overview of what the structure paradigm
is and then sort of an assignment where
we had to watch a film and then break
down the first act of that film of what
happens in every single scene and so
that sort of built on two more things
that we would learn later where we would
do breakdowns of entire scripts of
entire films
but that first class was just sort of an
introduction of terms and a basic
overview of what the structure was we
had a class called the short screenplay
and that was a class where we needed to
write 30 to 45 page script that could be
anything it could be a TV pilot it could
be a beginning of a feature it could be
a web series pretty much whatever we
wanted but that was taught by another
professor his name is Jared Rappaport a
much more freer sort of experience he's
a very nice I love him so much he's such
a great professor he he's definitely the
opposite of professor Edson and that
he's very free-flowing and he's very you
know follow your muse and follow your
inspiration and stuff like that and
every bit the successful screenwriter
that that Professor Henson was but we
started that first class with some
guided meditation oh cool if that's any
guys what's our whites and it was just
sort of us talking about ideas and sort
of tapping into the things that make us
want to be writers and the stories that
we want to tell so it was much more sort
of an individualistic class and figuring
out what
is that you want to say so that's what
that was it was you know a couple
exercises and in figuring out what are
the the conflicts that you're most
interested in what are the types of
people that you're most interested in
and then based on that you sort of
figure out and you sort of back into a
writing project that will help you
explore that so for some of us like I
ended up writing a spec script for an
HBO show called room 104 that that dealt
with a dysfunctional family because
that's that's kind of the thing that I'm
really interested in other students
wrote the beginnings of features like
the first acts of features that sort of
stuff but there were all different types
of projects there and then the third
class was the one-hour drama class and
that was taught by a woman named
Lawrence Walsh Hudson she was a story
editor on CSI Miami and she worked on a
number of other shows as a TV writer and
that was sort of us coming up with the
show that we wanted to write a spec for
so anyone our show we could write for
and it was us just sort of talking about
the different types of one-hour shows
the different genres
you know serial eye shows versus you
know kind of case of the week shows and
really just sort of that first class was
sort of boiling down what we had wanted
to tackle for the semester and just sort
of talking about life and the writers
room and stuff like that so that was fun
I ended up picking black mirror as a
show that I wanted to write a spec for
because there's a structure to it but
every episode is unique and not really
connected to the others so I was kind of
cheating I wanted to write a story as a
feature so I thought if I did it as a
black mirror spec that would work
so yeah those were the first three
classes that week it was that first week
wasn't that stressful because as all
semesters you have sort of a beginning
and intro before you really get into the
work and the real meat of the semester
but it was a great sort of you know
first step into you know what would be
two years of
raining and what was that first movie
that you watch that you dissected the
first one we watched I believe was
Legally Blonde oh great I think was the
first time that we did yeah it's awesome
yep and what were some of the terms that
you were introduced to he said there
were was it screenwriting time yeah yeah
so for professor Edison there were a
couple terms specific to his book and
specific to his analysis any time a hero
has something that they're trying to do
or that they're trying to learn about he
calls that a hero goal so the main
character in your story is trying to do
something at the very beginning of the
movie right so in the case of Legally
Blonde Reese Witherspoon's character is
getting ready for that date that she's
gonna have with her boyfriend that she
thinks he's going to propose to her at
right so she's getting ready for it and
then at when she actually gets to that
dinner
the boyfriend breaks up with her so
that's what she learned was that okay
her her goal is obviously not gonna
happen because she got news that
completely changed it that news he calls
fresh news so whenever you get fresh
news you now move on to a new goal as a
result of what you've learned so after
the breakup Reese Witherspoon's
character decides okay I have to find
out why he's breaking up with me so the
goal is then to learn why her boyfriend
is breaking up with her and then as
they're driving home she figures that
out and then she decides okay the reason
that she learns that he's going to law
school and that she's not the right kind
of girl for him so once she learns that
her next goal is okay I'm gonna get into
law school so I can prove to him that I
am the right kind of guy or a right kind
of girl for him so based on the fresh
news of okay and he he's breaking up
with me because I'm not in law school
her new goal her third goal is now I'm
gonna get into law school myself and
then that continues all the way through
the film and it evolves
she gets into school she finds out he's
already engaged to someone else then she
ends up working you know she to prove to
him that she's really the right kind of
girl she gets an internship at a law
firm and then gets involved in a case
and you know so all of that is to prove
that she really has the wherewithal to
be a good to be a strong person to be
you know a smart effective person in a
good lawyer so that's the journey she
goes on as a result of all of these
actions that she takes
you